in lesson four we are introduced to the  feminine and masculine of nouns which is  something that  you will  be  constantly faced with and having studied  french and spoken it for 40 50 years  there will always be times when i get  the noun the gender wrong or i don't uh  make the adjective agree and stuff like  that so it's one of these things that  just takes time to get used to  but there was an expression there  so right away we know that the speaker  is  a woman and we see the the e there at  the end  so these are all the e's and the a's  that indicate that we're dealing with  the feminine  and  here i just wanted to mention this it is  works for both masculine and feminine  but notice again that  in the comma  we don't hear the t because it's  followed by a consonant  and that's basically all there is  in this simple lesson i hope you enjoy  it